hello everyone and welcome to the tie
breaks of the semi-finals of the fide
grand prix currently being played in
belgrade it's an issue reverses dmitry
and draken and we've already covered one
of their classical games you've seen
that it was quite a game anish missed
that knight to h3 a very nice retreat
that would have won him the game he just
had to keep cool in the position uh but
here we have two rapid games uh we're
only going to show the second one but we
are going to show only a glimpse of the
first one just to give you an idea of
the whole day as it was it was a
very weird day
so let's uh
see what happened in game one so this is
the position in game one where the
players agree to a draw or rather after
d5 we started repeating the position
knight to f8 sorry about that
uh going after the knight um andre can
had the white pieces here he played
knight d4 on each one back knight g6
knights the e6 knights to f8 tonight's
the d4 and the knights the g696 and here
the players agree to a draw but before
we go into game two uh this is actually
a a wonderful position for black even
though it seems that it's white who's
dictating the tone of the battle uh but
after a move like queen to g4 it will
not be easy uh for uh white to period
the threats that come against this h2
pawn so to give you an example uh queen
goes back to help out with the defense
offers the queen trade we're going to
play queen h4 attack the h2 pawn and
once we defend this with h3 or g3 it
doesn't really matter we play queen e4
we grab hold of the uh only open file on
the board the e file and now as white
continues development let's say bishop
to f4 we're gonna play bishop to c5 and
here uh black has a clear advantage or
even if white continues in the the
strongest possible way let's say rookie
one we simply trade queens and after
this we play bishop captures on d for
doubling white spawns c captures the
rook capture 71 rook captures and now
knight to g6 and now you can see that
the double pawns are going to be an easy
target for for the black pieces or even
the king here
you might consider even something like
d6 to get rid of your double pawn but
black can just play c6 and if d5 you can
even play c5 and now king d7 uh the
bishop will get eliminated you're gonna
pick up the pawns and black will have an
awesome game so maybe not the greatest
of ideas to
go for an easy draw here but uh gary had
the black pieces he probably thought
okay i'm gonna get my chance with the
white pieces and then we have the game
two so this is what happened in game one
and this is now game two anish has the
white pieces here and he opens with e4
dimitri goes for the sicilian defense we
have c5 knight f3 we have e6 and now d4
so i'm going for this sort of a frenchy
sicilian c captures knight captures
knights to c6 knight to c3 and a6 we
have the taimano variation of the
sicilian knight captures b captures and
bishop to d3 so of course the black will
uh striking the center we have d5 uh
uneach castles and now knight to f6 so
this is nothing new this has all been
played before we have queen to f3
developing the queen bishop to b7 rook
to e1 and now bishop to e7 and sorry
about i just realized that i have left
the c on the little robot so let me just
quickly fix that so you guys don't
mistake this with a classical game as
this is a rapid game there we go
nicely done
uh and yeah uh players of course have to
play much quicker and here the position
is a known one there are a couple of
games where e5 was played but here we
have queen to g3 banish going after the
g7 pawn grabbing hold of this diagonal
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game uh so let's see
how black deals with this uh so white is
saying basically if you castle you're
gonna be in trouble uh but not really if
uh if i'm drinking castles here bishop
to h6 isn't really a threat because you
can just go back knight to e8 and the g7
pawn is nicely defended however it looks
a bit weird and maybe not something you
want to go into
in rapid time format if you don't have
everything uh worked out so instead
after g3 we have h5
uh not asking are you maybe interested
in a nice uh
g7 pawn but if you go for this rook g8
and after queen moves we're going to
move the queen castle queen side double
up rooks and the g file and uh well it's
going to be
not pleasant to play this with white so
instead after h5 we have just a nice h3
not allowing knight g4 and now king to
f8 now the g7 pawn is nicely defended we
have bishop to f4 and now pawn to h4
attacking the queen
queen goes to f3 and now king all the
way to g8 uh we have rook a to d1 by
anish and now knights the h5 going after
the dark square bishop so bishop to h2
nicely controlling the knight and bishop
to d6 uh offering a trade of bishop so
any straights here we have bishop
captures queen captures and now anish uh
blocks this diagonal by playing e5 and
he enjoys his position very much so here
we have queen to b4 and now knight to e2
uh remaneuvering the knight you don't
have to worry about the b2 pawn if the
queen captures rugby one will just grab
the bishop so that would be a terrible
blunder so g6 uh allowing knight to g7
to come to f5 as this bishop is a very
dangerous attacking piece and now c3
chasing the black queen away we know
that the b2 pawn is definitely not up
for grabs so queen to e7 and now we have
b4 uh starting expansion on the queen
side so the meter immediately challenges
this with a5 we have a3 and now uh we
have bishop to a6 offering a trade of
light square bishops uh that you could
go for but there's no need to rush in
knight to d4 first going for that c6
spawn
uh so bishop captures on d3 and now
queen captures on d3 you could also play
rook captures on d3 and he decides to
capture with the queen and now it's a
question what do you do with this pawn
mass on the queen side how do you deal
with this
well one way is to just play a captures
on b for a captures and c5 this is the
cleanest way to deal with things uh
white will capture on c5 you're going to
capture with the queen and everything is
perfectly fine however it's a rapid game
you always have to ask yourself but what
if white plays knight to c6 i'm going to
move my queen b5 is coming defending the
knight and already i've given white a
pass pawn is this really worth it well i
could play c4 queen b1 it looks weird
again i don't want to waste too much
time on this so instead andre can place
queen to b7 uh it's a very interesting
move but it also allows anish to
activate uh his rooks very rapidly so on
each place rook to b1 now comes queen to
a6 offering a queen trade and now b5 you
could also not go for this push as this
uh somewhat ruins your pawn structure
you could just move the queen let's say
queen d2 go g5 f6
all of these ideas are of course in the
air but we have to remind ourselves this
is rapid chess so here b5
c captures on b5 rook characters on b5
of course we are going to use this
opportunity to double our rooks and the
b file and now knight to g7 shifting the
knight over to f5 and now we have rook e
to b1 uh you don't win the queen by rook
to b8 check some of you guys are
probably thinking that rook captures
queen captures queen because there's
king h7 and now you've just helped black
uh get a safer square for his king so
instead just rookie to b1 nicely
doubling up here and queen to c8 now uh
and now what do you play here with white
it's a very tricky position uh however
the idea is that uh you want to play uh
queen uh queen to d2 and rook to b7 in
any order probably queen to d to follow
by rook to b7 get the queen to g5 to f6
uh and this is um well a very good way
to to go about this position however
anish plays rook to b6 instead uh he
wants to grab hold of the c6 square but
this allows queen to c5 now the queen
will not get locked out on the back rank
queen to f3 uh going for that uh f6
square and then now comes rook to f8
also you have to worry about rook to b7
going after f7 uh so here dimitary just
defends it with rook to f8 if you're
wondering do you have maybe time to
capture on a3 uh not really because it's
a super fun line so we're just gonna
show one of them if queen captures an a3
we just continue with queen f6 and now
after queen goes back we play rook to b7
and there really aren't all that many
moves for black here however we do have
a pass pawn now so we might as well
start pushing it
knight to c6 now the knight is coming to
e7 with check and let's say you go 98
attack the white queen 97 check king to
h7 and now queen to f3
again what can what can black play here
of course black can only push the pawn
a3 now we play knight captures and d5
and really not uh
nothing good is happening here we are
threatening rook captures on f7 which
will win the queen so king the g8 we
have to guard the f7 square now comes
knight to b6 we attack the rook and once
a2 is played because that's kind of the
only thing black has we're going to
defend with rook to a1 and once this
rook moves somewhere now comes knight to
d7 attacks the queen and after let's say
queen g7 rook to b8 and the black is now
completely tied down of course this
hypothetical line and anything else
could have happened but this is uh uh
pretty much with best play on both sides
what would happen so you can see that
black is completely busted let's say
king h7 we're gonna play queen g4 here
queen to h6 as you have to play
something and now we just go in for the
kill there was no defending this real
capture throw captures knight to f6
check and that's it uh you just end up
being up a full full piece and black has
nothing to show for it so it's a pretty
longish line but um that's kind of what
what the idea is if you if you rush with
queen captures on a3 so here rook to f8
adding a defender to the f7 pawn
uh now comes not rook to b7 but rook to
b8 by anish
and here uh andreikin says all right i'm
definitely going for the pawn now queen
captures on a3 and now comes rook
captures an f8 uh again this was one
position where anish could have won the
game pretty much on the spot but he had
to find the knight to b5
it's a tricky looking move attacks the
queen and once you bring the queen back
we play knight to d6 and now how do you
deal with this position okay you can
trade once let's say rook captures rook
captures with czech king h7 now rook b7
and your entire position just falls
apart so that's one way to do it uh but
again i have to stress uh this is a
rapid game anish played a rook captures
on f8 we have queen captures on f8 and
now knight to c6 uh but here just queen
back to c5 this is simply too much and
of course black will not give you uh any
any free tempe here to
go go for a rook lift or something like
that so here of course we have to move
the queen queen to c5 was played and now
rook to b8 check king h7 it doesn't look
uh
all that promising so instead anish goes
rook to b7 now comes knight f5 now we're
already having some counter play with
black knight e7 check
going for the tricky uh if the knight is
accepted knight captures an f6 then
queen f6 and now it's uh well uh uh
you're either getting checkmated after
this happens or you have to give back
the piece and the white will just be
better so instead uh dmitry just plays
king g7 moves the king and now uh we
have knight captures on g6 uh so this is
the kind of the last thing that anisha
thinks of you could also just capture
the knight this is perfectly fine and
after e captures you can push e6 and
chances are you will not lose this game
it's it's still a game of course
anything can happen but
everything is on the board however after
king to g7 anish played knight captures
on g6 he went for the mating attack but
now the position is completely winning
for andreikin uh only if you find the
correct idea so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the solution to
this it's not an easy one so you know
give it some time while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting queen
to c6 uh or queen to c8 you are uh an
amazing spotter of incredible ideas in
difficult positions and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show this is
exactly what andre andre can play queen
to c8 is a little bit more precise but
you could also play queen to c6 and then
queen c8 uh because uh well white just
can't
do anything about this the problem with
king capture on g6 is that now it's a
draw queen g4 checking h4 and you will
not be able to escape this perpetual so
this is kind of the best thing ganesh
can hope for unless black blunders and
of course gets checkmated so here
instead after queen to c6 uh what can a
niche do now the problem is if you play
rook to a7 now okay we have to bring our
queen back to c8 as that was the the
real idea queen c5 rook to d7 as the
rook only has b7 and d7 to use queen to
c8 we're gonna play rook to a7 now queen
to b8 and once the rook moves to d7 now
we play queen to e8 and that's kind of
the whole point of this uh using the
rook to remaneuver our queen to keep an
eye on the f7 pawn and now when we have
and
are keeping an eye on the f7 pawn the
rook moves and now we pick up the knight
here and now uh there is no perpetual
because after queen to g for checking h6
queen f4 check we go back queen h7 and
we don't have to worry about real
captures on f7 that was a big issue in
the in the previous line why the king
could not go to the seventh rank uh so
pretty crazy stuff i know but um
that's how good these guys are so
instead anish says all right i see what
you are doing queen to c6 a brilliant
move so rook captures an f7 and now king
captures on f7 knight captures on h8
with czech king to g7 and now queen to
h5 can anish do something here uh well
it's hard to say but he still has to
worry about the past a pawn so queen
captures on c3 and draken quickly
settles this uh as queen to e1 check
this falls then this check then a queen
to e1 check then this falls everything
will fall with check and there is
nothing anish can do about this knight
f7 he has to try and activate the knight
somehow queen e1 check now everything is
forced king to h2 queen captures on f2
knight to g5 now our knight is activated
and hopefully we can start doing
something but of course the black will
not allow this queen g3 check king g1
now queen the e1 check king h2 queen
captures on e5 with check king g1 queen
to e3 with check now we go king to h2
and queen to g3 check and here uh
andreikin is now black is just full of
tricks uh if white goes king to h1 we
can even play queen captures on h3
that's the good stuff here uh because
after g captures just knight uh
g3 with check forks the king and the
queen after the king moves you're gonna
pick up the pawn here knight captures e6
with king f6 and now you have a knight
uh a night king and pawn end game where
black is up two points and of course
completely winning so anish of course
not gonna allow this he plays king to g1
but now again we have queen to e1 check
king to h2 and of course the move from
the thumbnail queen to e1 with check
that's again the good stuff black uh the
black queen must be accepted now king
captures an h1 and not knight the g3
check and again the the end game is
completely winning king g1 knight
captures on h5 we have knight captures
and e6 with king f6 and now knight to c5
but of course anish will not resign this
both players are very low on time he
will try and trick dmitry somehow so
here king e5 came to f2 we have d4
king to e2 and now knights to f4 with
check going after the g2 pawn so king of
three defending not king d5 we chase
away the knight knight to a4 and now
knight to e6
uh we have g3 uh dimitri creates a pass
pawn h captures on g3 now comes h4 so
now the white one will also start
marching forward but as you can imagine
the knight can uh simply stop the pawn
at h7 uh regardless of what white tries
so here just d3 king captures on g3 and
now king to c4 again a very precise move
uh with a little time on the clock
because if you play d2 uh you allow a
niche to play king to f2 and now you
don't have queening uh because of night
night fork and it's just um well you're
not gonna be winning this game of course
you don't have to go for the queening of
the pawn the position is still winning
for black but uh you don't want to give
white any chances so here king to c4
h5 we have king to be three chasing away
the knight from these important squares
but of course if the knight moves then
it's just game over so h6 now comes
knight to f8 of course we stopped the
pawn and that's pretty much it anish
still finds another trick knight to c5
check came to c2 and the knight the e6
now hoping that if knight captures an e6
then the white pawn will queen still
this will be losing for white but uh you
know what are you going to do
but of course andre can just place d2
and he was in this position on move 63
that the players or rather that uh
dimitri enrique resigned the game uh
that ani resigned the game and that
means that dmitry and draken is the
other uh finalist who will face the
richard rapper tomorrow in the finals uh
that will take place um on saturday and
sunday so we're gonna have a have a
great match hopefully as both of them
are playing incredible fighting chess
and we can only hope that the finals
also go to the to the tie break so we
can enjoy this even more so here you
resign because once uh well let's say
you capture on f8 uh white black simply
doesn't care you bring a queen into the
game and even after h7 yes your uh pass
pawn is protected by the knight but it's
actually very simple queen d6 check king
g4 we pick up the knight we guard the
queening square that's it there's no
even question about the disposition
uh so
after queen to d2 anish resigned and
there there you have it so a real really
a tough break for anish because he was
winning in classical time format if you
haven't seen it do check it out i made a
video on it um a few days ago that
beautiful night stage 3 idea that anish
missed
then he missed clearly a better position
in game one of the rap it's probably
thinking i'm gonna push my chances with
white i don't want to force anything
with black even though the position was
much better and now uh having a
completely winning position uh in many
many moves uh he again allows uh dimitri
to wiggle out and take take the win
uh so a tough break for anish but that's
just you have to fight until the very
end and well uh andreikin is definitely
uh
a a great fighter it would seem
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it
looking forward to the finals uh i would
like to thank lucas de ocara jonathan
lay uh dave austin uh [ __ ] saxatilis uh
better surf caster than bob the garbage
man and philippe rambiakovsky for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals until it ends so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your friday